Steve Mariucci is in the house yes no
introduction right here live in our show
in Nashville what's up mooch
so you're recovered from last night
everything's good right ready for this
we are we are ready for this week I do
want to describe when I first met you
Oh Hahnemann when I first met you it was
in well I mean League meetings no no no
outside of that socially when I first
met hung out where did I see you for the
first time Pantheon Pantheon in Rome in
the Piazza Susie and I were were in
Italy and she Mucha just joined the NFL
Network we had just done the Super Bowl
together where you were I was my tryout
your tryout yeah and so Susie we're
having lunch at the Pantheon and she
goes I think that Steve Mariucci over
there might know what get out of here
I was in my my seersucker when in Rome
still can't for code we still can't find
gone it never made it back from the Pro
Bowl I don't know what an idiot I was
thinking I'm wearing a jacket like that
at the Pro Bowl anyway it's my fault but
you at the time in that photograph you
were wearing an NFL golf shirt that you
didn't pay for right now in an NFL Draft
2019 in these pants rich tea sir Under
Armour's pants from your pages from
coaching that game with Rodion Kyler
Maria Duane ask those guys tell me about
calamari in that game Steve he was he's
pretty quick I mean he gets on the field
man he just run around like whoa rich
about 11 of our other armored kids are
gonna get drafted in the first round
this year this year again every year I'm
unbelievable Oh what is happening with
calamari you think right now what is
going on in the Arizona front office
based on your experience of having been
in these conversations and being on
occasion maybe overruled or you saying I
want this guy I'm pounding the table
because I'm the coach I've got the
offensive system what is happening do
you think in Arizona I think they know
what they're gonna do but they haven't
mentioned it publicly okay they know
exactly what they're gonna do okay so
the hay is truly in the barns in the
barn unless the phone rings with an
Astra Nagato their offer ya can't refuse
it so but I think think about this rich
think about with cliff and cliffs a good
guy all right mm-hmm
here's a guy that that was recruiting
Cuyler Murray out of high school to
Texas Tech and he's had some good
quarterbacks over there right yeah
Patrick my Holmes and Baker all kinds of
guys Case Keenum
is from Texas Tech anyway he goes over
to SC and all of a sudden he becomes the
head coach the stars are aligned right
now for these guys in my mind all right
for cliff and for Cuyler Murray Cuyler
Murray committed to Billy Beane over
there at the 9th pick for the Oakland
A's and that that was gonna be a done
deal I went I went fishing with Billy
Beane after that and it was a done deal
he felt really good about it
not so fast Billy okay no and so so off
sudden he changed his mind why did he
change his mind because somebody's in
his ear hey now you can be a real eye
pick in the NFL and make more money than
in baseball and ride a bus so so right
now
luckily Kliff Kingsbury and the
cardinals pick first and are trying to
put together a scheming system that here
at he's not coming in to run the West
Coast offense he's coming in to run they
hired a scheme in Arizona that college
scheme well who fits it the best Kyler
Murray is perfect fit so right now the
stars are aligned for Kyler right a
going to that scheme right and for cliff
and Arizona to implement that kind of
college offense and they're not a very
good team right Larry Fitzgerald gonna
be one that one more year and then he's
gone so they've got a rebuilding process
so they're gonna do it together so why
wouldn't they go ahead and do what you
just mentioned with Murray and then call
up Washington and say all right you need
a quarterback we got your guy and Rosen
we know you might be interested in him
let's talk about it and in return we get
Case Keenum these perfect knows who
knows perfect mentor who knows the
system who knows Kingsbury I mean it you
when talking about stars aligned and
then you get maybe whatever you can get
for I mean whatever you have to do
second if even if it's a third round
pick
you're getting more picks this year to
supplement what they can do no doubt for
Kingsbury
on the spot with more like it that's
what makes the most sense that again
what do it would be stars are aligned
cuz cuz case would be a better to than
anybody there here's an experienced guy
without a huge ego right that's the kind
of knows all the moving parts and
probably could start for a while if need
be but what makes no sense right is you
can't have two kids in the in the
quarterback room right you can't keep
Rosen that would because gasoline in
matches right Josh Rosen is this smart
guy that he moved up to number ten
correct it wasn't just the tenth pick
they moved up to get them right and so
that's gonna be a gonne their face just
by getting rid of him they gotta move
them if they take Murray correct yes
yeah no no and that's part of the reason
why they don't have the leverage as I've
been saying the reason why you might not
be hearing about a first rounder for
Rosen or a second round or for Rosen has
nothing to do with Rosen's ability has
to do with the Cardinals leverage
position but you know they got it
if they take Murray they've got to trade
they've got to flip Rosen this sense
that they would keep both kids and
figure it out makes no sense to me they
can't do that but I think there will be
other suitors besides Washington that
would want Joshua like who let's say the
Giants don't take a quarterback at six
let's say they take a great defensive
player because there's their the hole
he'll be there it is gentleman's going I
can get a Pro Bowler on number six on
defense yes hey and then you look at
seventeen rich and there are a handful
of quarterbacks that are going to be
there to choose from what do you like
best from that spot if I assume in
Haskins is definitely not going to be at
seventeen which one of these kids do you
like that you may have put on the grease
board you've met you know walk - yeah I
don't know all them personally tonight
to make a quarterback evaluation and
decisions yes I want to live with the
kid for a while you know I mean sure see
if he knows how to eat with a knife and
fork everything about all right but but
Josh Rosen might be the most game
ready let's say the Giants trade for
Josh Rosen just whatever they give him a
- okay you got a guy that started games
he was three and ten he won in Lambeau
he won in Lambeau he beat the Niners
twice okay he's he's more ready than
drew lock or Daniel Jones but then you
got the Cutcliffe factor okay that says
hey Daniel Jones is a lot like Eli and
Peyton and he can do this as well but
not this as well it's a good fit you
know I think he's gonna have a voice in
some of this at least the evaluation
process but Josh Rosen is more ready to
back up Eli this year than all the other
guys and so but if they if they say we
don't need a backup
Eli never gets hurt we can go with one
of the Drude luck nothing wrong with
Drew Locke right he said he's a pretty
athletic guy now and and he's a leader
and a starter and all that for a long
time
and Daniel Jones has got something to
him he's a tall guy that can run and so
you know in doing Haskins does he fall
that far he might oh that would be
something that would be something
surprise that's why the Giants have all
those choices Steve Mariucci here on the
Rich Eisen show what did you make of
Ian's report about Mayock send in the
scouts home and all that business so I
texted with Mike I was gonna say talk to
Mike but if you talk if you text and you
say I talk to him is that lying or is
that that is texting you communicated
with Mike you communicated with Mike
yeah that's what I did so he said much
much he said this is not all that
unusual and it's really not okay you got
to remember those are Reggie McKinsey
Scouts or not Mike scouts they didn't
send the coaches home because those
coaches are loyal to Gruden and they
know not to you know loose lips sink
ships right but the scouts were Reggie
Scouts and they were on the end of their
contracts anyway they were going to be
replaced and so their evaluations were
in they read reports they got all he
needed from all he needed from him there
was no reason to have him help make
decisions when everybody else in the
building was still there so it's not
unusual I've been in places where you
lock the door and you put the thing over
it and nobody can go in there you know I
cover windows up you mean you cover the
board you know the you know my board in
my office said to you
come down lock it so nobody can go in
there and say hey yeah we got we got
Haskins rated number two no it's it's
it's it's not for the whole building to
share with their neighbor okay it's it's
private and sometimes those things
change and so that's that's all that is
and sometimes when those things get out
and the your current quarterback here's
where you've evaluated these other young
kids and you don't take that young
quarterback now you got a headache with
your current quarterback when you didn't
really need to you all you need to do is
you send the scouts home early I I
didn't have a problem about hearing that
no and it's what everyone's like oh well
there's dysfunction in Oakland and
they're paranoid up there it you know
it's good it was it was probably the
prudent thing to do
yeah did you ever send scouts home like
that not send them home because I've
been in organizations that the scouts
that were on board yes we're coming back
the next year got it
well you know unless you were gonna
replace one or something but I've never
been in that situation but certainly
locked up the information and it were
restrictive as to who's in that room on
a rough day yes Steve Mariucci here all
right I'm gonna I'm gonna go here with
you because I love you and you can
handle it Oh mm draft third round we do
this every year I don't know about
I mean just but I haven't really I still
go to sleep after that night I I do I I
apologize for not drafting Tom Brady
well what happened in the trash room
that makes you go Giovani car mazi I
mean was Walsh in there who's in there
yeah who's in there it's you Walsh Terry
Donahue Marty Morningwood great nap all
of us all the all the coaches everybody
right okay so let me why don't you just
roll tape from last year's Ponyo first
of all it's the show with a podcast so
other than that so multi-platform just
saying we're on it I'm gonna have to
give you a bit of a history lesson okay
we had a kid named Steve Young all right
furred lefty drove me nuts I'd say
listen Steve and this offseason go home
and learn to throw with your right hand
because I don't want to flip every play
I've went depending on who the
anyway so he was an athletic guy we're
in the West Coast offense you move him
around and let's change launch point
yeah
so we previously we drafted a guy named
Jim Druckenmiller from Virginia Tech big
strong guy and a good-looking girlfriend
oh so so anyway was her name Julie
Sweeney so we learned my stomach just
crammed laughing we learned that he was
a big strong guy is like his work up day
was pushing his tire over and he was
like lifting weights but he was real of
them anyway he was a drop bad guy right
and we learned that he's not going to be
able to do the things we want to do with
a movement package that's what we like
that's how were the 49ers make there hey
so we kind of we kind of started
differentiating the drop back category
in the athletic category okay Tom Brady
your guy from Michigan was in the drop
back category as he was and not and and
and we probably to this day if you watch
that that show that I was on you know
what I mean with the Brady six it's a
very pretty good show this anyway
I mentioned that we put too much
emphasis on what the measurables the
five to eight or whatever the slowest
forty ever recorded by a quarterback
combine we put too much emphasis on that
and put him in that category alright we
did measures art or a spine or those
kinds of things right but he wasn't even
much of a consideration cuz he was in
that bunch we needed the plus Steve
Young's coming back we I was hoping
Steve Young would be there another ten
years man so I could keep living in the
bay and so so anyway long story short
geo car mozzie yeah
not because he was Italian rich with
Hofstra I know but he was a Rhodes
Scholar
he was the point guard on the basketball
team he was for seven he was six two he
was you know he was one of those guys
that we say well he's an athletic guy he
doesn't have to play we can mold him we
can mold him I didn't know he was gonna
be a goat farmer and so
but so we took him and it was it was
because he was in that bunch of
quarterbacks that we liked as athletes
that we could groom yeah didn't want to
play him right away I was hoping he'd
never have to play because Steve Young
was my guy so did you ever at any point
in time have a quiet moment with Bill
Walsh and going man did you interview
after he goes easy the exact right guy
he's gonna be great he's gonna be this
because of this this and this and but
would you ever revisit the issue with
with Bill that's a yes you don't want to
say baseball listen to me they both
start at the same time in the Hall of
Fame Game
mm-hmm the Niners in the Patriots in the
Hall of Fame so Brady and karmas you
were on the same canton field yeah see
you it in and Gio's listening to this
I'm sure all right watch TV 12 might be
out there too
and and Gio had a rough start three of
seven 19 yards but you know don't be
just a stat guy because it was it was
hard spine but there was there was
command in the huddle all right angio
was struggling getting the plays out and
he was so nervous right poor kid was so
nervous and and Tom went in in the
fourth quarter and and and I didn't
expect Tom to be great nobody did at
that no I what I'm saying to you is have
you ever at any moment before he passed
had a chance to sit down with Bill Walsh
and say man if we had only known at the
time we were choosing between the coat
and a goat farm he wasn't the goat dish
and he wasn't he didn't farm yet we we
eventually who knew at the time here's
the goat and here's a man who farmed
goats goat in the conversation I know
it's it's a slight difference was a goat
server just blink once
yes two for no did you ever say remember
that conversation I do remember when
wouldn't bill and I and everybody on
board decided see we sent geo we sent
him away but but then he got hurt he got
hurt his shoulder man give him a break
he's a good kid it wasn't his fault
wasn't his fault we just we just thought
we could groom him which I apologize
that we put you through we'll finish up
the show with mooch I have no idea we'll
talk about but you know it'll be great
that's next on the returns
all right what a show we've had so far I
want to thank Charles Davis for being
here in our number one Kevin Calabro the
longtime voice of Sonics basketball and
now the voice of Blazers basketball
talking about that Damian Lillard dagger
that he's stuck in the Oklahoma City
Thunder last night and I want to thank
again Steve Mariucci hanging out here
for when I was alone I'm waiting for
Frank Caliendo to show up oh man okay by
the way he loves you he does wonder he
does it you you know that is he any good
he's pretty good yeah what's the mood
chance he says the hands your hands are
pretty yours Farley ism's that's what he
says yeah that's crazy
yeah I love him he's in anytime guest
man you are too ok score too much did
you go karaoke last night we did without
me well it's kind of a draft for
tradition didn't we do that right with
me you and Eric Stonestreet so cause oh
we had our first dinner we had a nice
dinner together and then you know muchif
was gonna pack it in I jumped in a cab I
was trying to jump in a cab but in Eric
Stonestreet grabbed me by the collar
anybody know you're not going in there
we're going to karaoke and so it was
like a lot when the band was playing and
you guys I have that video you guys all
got on stage what is video friends in
low places that's right yeah yeah that
was bad cuz after I mean yeah kept going
forever it's like when are we gonna get
off this stage embarrassing the family
but that was fun so and then we've done
it with we've done it with more
Joel and Kara and we've done it with
Kara Henderson's need yeah but that was
in New York that was years ago for New
York of draft it's amazing how many
aides now I think it's been what is it
now five years since the last denna
felony and NYC draft right you know what
yeah I don't know what 10 years or
wherever we did it together in Radio
City Music and do it anymore because the
Rockettes are scheduling or whatever I
was depressed but I like this I know
because Chicago did a heck of a job that
Philly was amazing Philly at 70,000
people watching you you know right and
then and then Nationals off the charts
again this is this is fun I just hope
tomorrow night if the weather does in
fact affect something then the NFL might
rethink we got to have it where we
figure out something where the weather
can't affect the broadcast because again
this is about broadcast television now
you know they've included ABC now after
one year ago they included Fox they want
to make it big they want to make it like
the you know State of the Union where
you can watch it on many different
channels is huge it just takes
everything over so it's about the
broadcast and they want to have a huge
event making it look big a hundred
thousand people in a big NFL American
city like say Nashville and have the
visual and have it a big event but if
it's gonna you know I mean if lightning
hits tomorrow night I don't want to keep
saying it but right now it looks like
it's a 74 70 percent chance of a
thunderstorm right when they're putting
the Cardinals on the clock I don't know
if it's gonna affect that or they'll
just say well we're gonna have it in
Vegas whether it's you know the only
thing that can happen is you know Mike
Tyson's Tigers could break out of there
you know I don't know what's gonna make
it but I agree with you cuz me being a
native New Yorker obviously taking at
Radio City I was bummed yeah it was fun
you know but this has been really good
moving it around and letting all these
other cities bid on it too ya know
and if it starts raining yeah people are
gonna go in the bars and all the clubs
and they're they're gonna be happy
because they're gonna write it's the
lightning that I know if you're thinking
I'm thinking about too is that the thing
I enjoyed about
the chicago draught was after years of
hearing the draft halt go crazy over a
jet pick or a giant pick it was
bears-packers Vikings right it was in
totally different universe of fans that
could drive they're obviously having it
in in Nashville now what then Titans go
on the clock it'll be big
maybe when the Colts go on the clock
there's some booing he Falcons go on the
clock you know I mean was just an
hour-long flight from Atlanta here and
what if the Saints go on the clock
Falcons fans are booing and vice versa
you know and I flew in yesterday rich
from San Francisco there were people on
the plane coming from the bay for this
event that's great so somewhere Niner
fans yeah or Raider fans because they're
fired up they have three picks right but
there was a father and a son that had
New England Patriot hats on and all this
stuff
people come in or they're making this a
little vacation a little event with you
know some good bonding time with dad
it's it's amazing right yeah the
interest in this kind of things great
yet last year we were in Dallas the
Redskins are on the clock people are
booing like crazy Giants are on the
clock it was great you know I so so
moving it around shows off different
passionate fan bases which is what the
NFL wants to show they want to show off
big great huge events in an American NFL
city like Nashville and show it off like
I said Friday and Saturdays weather is
good I just hope tomorrow that you and I
aren't like buggin out where we might be
in a shelter tomorrow night
you know yeah so make sure that the
food's ready I know but you'll get that
right oh yeah I'll have my briefcase
full of beef jerky I can't wait I love
this week the fame - beef jerky
briefcase
thanks for coming on hey thanks all
right guys have fun we're just here deep
Marriott she's here right on the Rich
Eisen show for more of the Rich Eisen
show tune - audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV for free on BR live or download
the Rich Eisen show app